hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com
so for those who don't know me yet i've
been working as a professional trader
for the past six years in hong kong
and i've decided guys a few months ago
to create my youtube channel
because guys i want to show you all the
different tools and techniques that i
use at work
to actually set up my trades and to make
money
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and most importantly yes if you
want to know how to use it yourself
you are in the right place so today i
want to make an update on
clvs clovis let's get into it
[Music]
so i do regular updates on this stock as
well because the stocks that
to me technically look beautiful all
right so this is a pharmaceutical
company so i'm not looking at the
fundamentals which is very important but
all the information is contained in the
flows already this is how i do my trades
and this is working so i don't really
care about like you know what i do what
i care about is that what people think
of it
and here i can tell you that look at the
high volume here all right
people are bullish and they're gonna
push the price higher this is
my longer term analysis breakout here i
connected the recent highs that i had
here
re-testing here very messy we went
higher
rejected right away let me go on the
shoulder time frame guys
and analyze what happened recently so i
did i think my last video
something like this now so this was the
strong breakout we had so i did my last
video around this level
so okay so here what is happening guys
you know we have this consolidation
we could not have it that's true we
could have just gone higher but here
it's like you know nothing is happening
all this price action is
not important yes because the associated
volume are low where does
shift values were high here and here
right at this level
so to me the eight is actually the price
it should it should be i mean
this is the price that the most people
agreed on in the past week
you know where we we had the most
liquidity so here
if we want to try to understand when
possibly we're gonna start going higher
again let's going to show the time frame
and let's try to find
some support levels and resistance
levels clearly
the 200 period moving average on the
hourly timeframe is support guys
here once okay here a bit messy but
three four five six seven times here it
was tested
it acted perfectly where are our
resistance
as usual guys you look at the recent
past and you try to find some
consolidation
here consolidation here rejection but
slightly higher
689 is my level 690 all right
you can call it 685 okay this area guys
this area let's call it 685
is the area of resistance so we might
see something
like this again being rejected coming
here being rejected and suddenly we're
going to break it we're going to retest
it and then we're going to go to the
next one
so this is what we're looking for we're
looking on the short term to break 680
then the next resistance is going to be
here of course
and this one is going to be maybe more
important so 8 is going to be the next
resistance to overcome
and if we do then we can finally go to
the target
which is guys once again 15 this is my
let's say medium term target so i can
find it by two different methods
so first here you know the the maximum
that i had here right so
17 something like this and then i use
fibs because fibs actually work very
well guys on this
hot stocks all right and if i use fibs
the 1.618 is
very close to this so 16 17 guys
is my level as a target for the
medium term so i would give it three
months something like this
let's see if it makes sense you know
something like this
you know even maybe some more correction
and you know arriving here
i mean i don't know if this is gonna
happen you know but this is
something that we can expect so maybe
around end of may
maybe june so let's see if i'm right
let's see if i'm right on this
once again guys if i change if my view
is like you know
different i would let you know for now
we are bullish if we break six
uh things might go again lower but i
mean it's of course not my preferred
scenario because i'm very bullish on the
stock
so let's see what happens and i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys